I live in Utah a place known for having
some of the most awe-inspiring natural
landscapes on this planet it's easy to
be overwhelmed by these amazing views
and to be really fascinated by these
sometimes alien looking formations as a
scientist I love observing the natural
world but as a cell biologist I'm much
more interested in understanding the
natural world at a much much smaller
scale I'm a molecular animator and I
work with other researchers to create
visualizations of molecules that are so
small they're essentially invisible
these molecules are smaller than the
wavelength of light which means that we
can never see them directly even with
the best light microscopes so how do I
create visualizations of things that are
so small we can't see them scientists
like my collaborators can spend their
entire professional careers working to
understand one molecular process to do
this they carry out a series of
experiments that each can tell us a
small piece of the puzzle one kind of
experiment can tell us about the protein
shape while another can tell us about
what other proteins that might interact
with and another can tell us about where
it can be found in a Cell and all of
these bits of information can be used to
come up with a hypothesis a story
essentially of how a molecule might work
my job is to take these ideas and turn
them into an animation this can be
tricky because it turns out that
molecules can do some pretty crazy
things but these animations can be
incredibly useful for researchers to
communicate their ideas of how these
molecules work they can also allow us to
see the molecular world through their
eyes I'd like to show you some
animations a brief tour of what I
consider to be some of the natural
wonders of the molecular world first off
this is an immune cell these kinds of
cells need to go crawling around in our
bodies in order to find invaders like
pathogenic bacteria this movement is
powered by one of my favorite proteins
called actin which is part of what's
known as the cytoskeleton unlike our
skeletons actin filaments are constantly
being built and taken apart the actin
cytoskeleton plays incredibly important
roles in our cells they allow them to
change shape to
around to adhere to surfaces and also to
gobble up bacteria actin is also
involved in a different kind of movement
in our muscle cells act in structures
form these regular filaments that look
kind of like fabric when our muscles
contract these filaments are pulled
together and they go back to their
original position when our muscles
relaxed other parts of the cytoskeleton
in this case microtubules are
responsible for long-range
transportation they can be thought of as
basically cellular highways that are
used to move things from one side of the
cell to the other unlike our roads
microtubules grow and shrink appearing
when they're needed and disappearing
when their job is done the molecular
version of semi-trucks are proteins
aptly named motor proteins that can walk
along microtubules dragging sometimes
huge car goes like organelles behind
them this particular motor protein is
known as dining and it's known to be
able to work together in groups that
almost look at least to me like a
chariot of horses as you've seen the
cell is this incredibly changing dynamic
place where things are constantly being
built and disassembled but some of these
structures are harder to take apart than
others though and special forces need to
be brought in in order to make sure that
structures are taken apart in a timely
manner that job is done in part by
proteins like these these doughnut
shaped proteins of which there are many
types in the cell all seem to act to rip
apart structures by basically pulling
individual proteins through a central
hole when these kinds of proteins don't
work properly the types of proteins that
are supposed to get taken apart can
sometimes stick together and aggregate
and that can give rise to terrible
diseases such as Alzheimer's and now
let's take a look at the nucleus which
houses our genome in the form of DNA in
all of our cells our DNA is cared for
and maintained by a diverse set of
proteins DNA is wound around proteins
called histones which enables cells to
pack large amounts of DNA into our
nucleus these machines are called
chromatin remodelers and the way they
work is that they basically scoot the
DNA around these histones and they
enabled allowed new pieces of DNA to
become exposed this DNA can then be
recognized by other machinery in this
case this large molecular machine is
looking for a segment of
that tells it it's at the beginning of a
gene once it finds a segment
it basically undergoes a series of shape
changes which enables it to bring in
other machinery that in turn allows the
genes get turned on or transcribed this
has to be a very tightly regulated
process because turning on the wrong
gene at the wrong time can have
disastrous consequences scientists are
now able to use protein machines to edit
genomes I'm sure all of you have heard
of CRISPR CRISPR takes advantage of a
protein known as caste 9 which can be
engineered to recognize and cut a very
specific sequence of DNA in this example
to cast nine proteins are being used to
excise a problematic piece of DNA for
example a part of a gene that may give
rise to a disease cellular machinery is
then used to basically glue the two ends
of the DNA back together as a molecular
animator one of my biggest challenges is
visualizing uncertainty all of the
animations I've shown to you represent
hypotheses how my collaborators think a
process works based on the best
information that they have but for a lot
of molecular processes we're still
really at the early stages of
understanding things and there's a lot
to learn the truth is that these
invisible molecular worlds are vast and
largely unexplored to me these molecular
landscapes are just as exciting to
explore as a natural world that's
visible all around us thank you
[Applause]
[Music]